now let's get to the bottom all this
with jeff bell
he's the president of broward sheriff's
office uh office
deputies association who is also a
sheriff's deputy himself
it's good to see you sir thank you so
much for joining us tonight
uh these new reports that came out
absolutely the new reports that came out
now have a total of four sheriff's
deputies
who did not enter that school building
as the shooting was taking place what do
you know about this tonight
i've heard rumors about that report
myself but i have
nothing to substantiate any of those
claims are factual
at this time well scott peterson let's
start with him because he has resigned
he was apparently behind a police
vehicle
with his gun drawn at the time that
other
officials showed up at the scene can you
walk us through what
protocol is for this type of active
shooter situation jeff well
for the active shooter deputy peterson
being the first officer on scene
he did what he was trained to do at the
beginning for the first minute responded
directly to the
area where shots were being fired called
out to location called in
other support units that were arriving
for backup but at that point
he stopped there of what he needed to do
as law enforcement officials we know
that every day when we go to work that
there's a chance that we may not come
home to our family members
and we accept that responsibility and
when we hear an active shooter i don't
care if it's within a school
a mall a house or an office building
when you are the first person there on
scene
every second that you delay going into
that building and every single gunfire
that you hear
from inside that building that means
that there's another innocent life being
lost
and it's unacceptable not to go inside
that building we know that risk when we
put the uniform on every single day
and we have to live up to that oath that
we take now do you know officer peterson
no i do not i've only had one
conversation with him and what what
occurred in that conversation
uh just uh to brief them what was about
to transpire within the next hour
in terms of the the administrative moves
that were going to happen in terms of
being suspended without pay and an
internal affairs investigation would
start
well the coral springs police are
apparently the ones who are
talking and that's why we got this new
report about the three broward uh
deputies who showed up and also didn't
enter the building
so why would the coral springs officers
express their frustration if they had
entered the building
or if this hadn't occurred doesn't that
given the fact that we have
again 17 dead and we have more than a
week has transpired
we still don't have the clear tick tock
on what happened that seems
a little much don't you think given the
public outcry here
well given the public outcry i can say
there's a lot of chaos on scene that
night
i i don't doubt the the actions of some
of the coral springs police officers
that were there that day
however i don't know enough information
to comment if those were the first
officers on scene
or if those officers that went into the
building first from coral springs they
came out and then they saw additional
deputies
so i don't have enough information to
comment at that rate at this time
sheriff israel uh basically echoed what
you said
uh about how this guy should have
peterson should have engaged the shooter
you're there shots are ringing out you
don't stay stand outside
you go in and that's like the
firefighters at 9 11 they went up in the
building
when you know everybody else was leaving
that's just that's your job that's what
you do
that's the danger of being a police
officer but you actually have made
comments about
the school board in broward county and
you lay some
some blame frankly on them for what
happened explain that to us
yes i do i think that's the one entity
in this whole conversation that has not
been brought up
the the some of the fault that i put on
the broward county school board
for years they know that the schools
have been soft targets
and they claim that they want to have
better police presence inside the
schools and they want tougher security
but yet they do not want to cough up the
money to pay for that better security
and fortify their schools and have
better designs they don't want that
and then when they are fortunate enough
to have a school resource deputy on
scene
an armed police presence a lot of the
liberal thinking
principles that are on campus there they
don't want the police officers making
arrests
on campus and they don't want the drugs
to be found on campus
and they don't want the warrants to be
served on campus because it looks like
there's bad stats at the school
so i place a lot of blame on the school
board with that and some of the programs
that they've initiated with the state
attorney in the sheriff's office in the
years past
for example the promise program nobody
wants to fill the
the jails with juveniles every police
officer will agree on that
so the promise program is a intervention
program
where we can stop filling the juvenile
jails with
with kids and we can get them into some
alternative programs
but the problem is within when that
program started
we took all discretion away from the law
enforcement officers
to an effect an arrest if we choose to
now there's a lot of parents out there
that are screaming for help in terms of
mental health
services well it seems like that was the
case here
right well we had 23 calls go to the
broward sheriff's office
about this family some were about
nicholas cruz's brother
others were about cruz and still you
know
including calls regarding his potential
for violence
and again the you're the expert here you
represent the union here but
23 calls to one house and you add that
with the fbi
uh tips that they got in 2016 and as
early as
is in november and apparently another
one in in february
uh this is just this is wild stuff
i mean red flag after red flag after red
flag
it is they are looking into that right
now
with those calls but i can tell you it's
not an uncommon thing
where we spend two three four five times
a week
that we respond to the same house for
the same problem over and over again
and so what your limitations are what
you the only way you can
i mean you could sit down with nicholas
cruz correct i mean
i imagine he didn't seem too bright i
imagine you could sit down and just
ask them questions can i look around
right could i look around you have any
guns can i see where they are can i see
where they're stored
that conversation do you have any idea
whether that took place
i do not have any of that information
right now as part of an internal affairs
investigation yeah
it is uh but i'm not privileged to
comment on that because it's an ongoing
uh investigation i'd be violating state
statute by commenting on that
uh the nra demonization that's going on
right now
is unlike anything i've ever seen i mean
they're trying to basically take them
off television
kill off all the businesses that you
know take their ads and so forth give
discounts to nra members
what's your sense on that i firmly
believe this is not a gun issue i've
said this from day one
and i'll hold that belief until the day
i die
it's not the gun that's the problem it's
the person behind the gun
that is the problem and the problem that
we face here today
is not going to be a simple fix and i'm
afraid to say that i don't even think
that there's going to be an outcome
that's going to fix this problem
because until we can link the mental
health records
into the criminal background checks that
we do to purchase a firearm
we're not going to see if a person had a
mental health issue
so that has to be resolved with the the
medical association and the hipaa law
violations
to release that information
i hear you but sheriff israel yesterday
or today said
what i think we need to do in america is
something different have less guns i
think he
means fewer less guns on our streets not
more guns so he's taken a different view
from you
that's the sheriff yeah he is he is my
boss and he is my sheriff
correct he is my boss and he is my
sheriff and he does sign my paychecks
uh but that doesn't mean that i have to
have the same opinions as the sheriff
does
i think we need to intervene with the
people that hold the gun
not the gun itself so until we address
the the real
problem which is the mental health issue
and and the the
the attitude of the state attorney's
office of releasing these people out on
the street
nothing's going to change deputy sheriff
bell thank you so much for joining us
tonight we'll be following
every aspect of this ongoing
investigation